willkommen zurück hierbei viertel nach
acht bei bild live mit spannenden gästen
spannenden meinungen und großen
emotionen der top der schlagzeilen was
patricia riekel was hat sie heute am
meisten bewegt also was mich wirklich
geärgert hat das war ein bild wie putin
angela merkel bei ihrer abschiedstournee
einen rosenstrauß überreicht das könnte
man ja jetzt für charmant halten sie für
sehr nett aber in wahrheit ist das total
gemein denn in meinen augen ist das eine
provokation gewesen so
verabschieden jetzt mal mutti und jetzt
ist dann schluss mit dem frauen gewöhnt
haben wir mal endlich damit auf ich
glaube dass angela merkel den guten 16
jahre lang ziemlich auf die nerven
gegangen ist weil sie ist ja selbst
bewusst und sie kunst nicht vor und sie
hatten eigentlich so behandelt wie man
so als mutter ein kind behandelt so ein
bisschen nachsichtig das bisschen ads
hat und ein bisschen starrsinnig ist
sonst ist man halt dann so laufen und
sagt ja ich habe schon alles ist schon
alles gut und ich glaube dass putin sich
gelegentlich bei dieser gelassenheit
diese ausgestrahlt hat wie so ein dummer
jungen bisschen gefüllt hat und jetzt
hat es irgendwie heimgezahlt
alexander saal also das ist klangvoll im
kreml hat sie ihre abschiedsrede
gehalten und da sieht man schon mit
wessen geistes diese männer da sind die
haben in der ersten reihe die putin
vertraute haben alles die journalisten
am das beobachtet haben geplaudert
geredet gelacht bisschen laschet mäßig
und wenn sie vorne von wirklich
wichtigen themen gesprochen hat normalen
syrien ukraine und so weiter und so fort
aber die haben das ignoriert und dann
überreicht ihr putin den blumenstrauß so
ein bisschen wie so ein muttertags
sträußchen mit der mann
mutti dankeschön sagt so vielleicht hat
es auch noch von der tanke geholt so
saßen weil es aus ist es storchen und er
ist ja ein meister in der bild botschaft
das weiß man von putin wie er sich
selbst inszeniert mit nackten oberkörper
beim angeln oder bei der bärenjagd und
er weiß genau was dieses bild mit frau
merkel macht die steht davor eben mit zu
einem blumenstrauß ein ganz unangenehmer
moment wohin damit wie bedankt man sich
ja ist es jetzt eine mann-frau situation
kann es aber doch nicht sein dass stehen
sich die zwei der mächtigsten
staatsoberhäupter gegenüber
normalerweise kriegst du dann einen
orden oder porzellan ding und ich weiß
der putin liebt es seine gegner aus dem
konzept zu bringen das war damals also
den hund mit in den offiziellen empfang
nahm natürlich hat der hund nicht
gebissen aber von merkel markt keine
hunde und es war auch so eine kleine
provokation aber ist es nicht vor allem
auch weil putin natürlich propaganda
denn für sein land er will propaganda
und die bilder mit ich geb dir übrigens
erst mal 100 notwendige recht ich glaube
manchmal verstehen frauen besser als
männer dass diese blumenstrauß macht
jedes level in und macht ein bisschen
klein ja aber ich glaube viel schlimmer
fand ich eigentlich merkels lächeln
dabei auf einem der bilder die um die
welt ging hat sie noch nicht geguckt er
so man hat gedacht dass ein beste
freunde ich verstehe immer dass uns
nicht so leichtes zu russland zu sagen
nein danke wir haben auch weniger
rohstoffe ich verstehe viele sachen aber
dieser kuschelkurs unserer
bundesregierung mit putin geht mir so
dermaßen gegen den strich er sich den
blumenstrauß noch auf ein anderes podest
heben wollen würde und sagen merkel ist
reich also da bin ich auch muss ich
sagen peter riecke voll und ganz bei
meiner kollegin lena ich fand das
problematische nicht dass putin angela
merkel diesem sumpf haus geschenkt hat
sondern dass ihnen freundlich annimmt
als wäre das das normalste geschenk von
einem der freundliche männer der welt
erstens ich würde von nichts und wir
hatten eben was wladimir putin gibt
einfach schon aus dem gedanken dass das
vergiftet es gibt ja einige denn das
nicht überlebt haben irgendwas berührt
zu haben was würde ich das gut ihn oder
seine leute wurden zwei ganz wichtiger
punkt man kann immer sagen ja der ist ja
nun mal da und wir das jetzt mal mit dem
frechen da würde ich sagen wladimir
putin hat ungefähr 900 meter luftlinie
vom kanzleramt einen dissidenten in den
kopf schießen lassen ich würde jetzt
egal ob mann oder frau keine blumen von
dem alter bin ich übrigens extrem was
sie denn tun sollen
man kann natürlich sagen er hat
wenigstens seinen hund diesmal nicht
rausgelassen das ist ein fortschritt und
ist nicht mit freiem oberkörper
reingekommen aber das war es eigentlich
das glaube ich für frau merkel
enttäuschende ist am ende ihrer amtszeit
wenn sie ein geschenk oder ein ergebnis
von dieser reise hätte mitbringen wollen
dann hätte das eine vereinbarung sein
müssen dass die vertrag über die
durchleitung von gas durch die ukraine
über 2024 hinaus verlängert wird das war
auch das ziel was sie hatte und sie ist
mit leeren händen oder nur mit einem
blumenstrauß der alles teil alles was
sie dazu gesagt haben verhältnis frauen
männer man sieht es ihm ohne ein
ergebnis von ihrem letzten besuch
zurückgekommen und insofern bleiben wir
in der situation dass das verhältnis zu
russland heute zu in deutschland und
russland so schlecht ist wie es lange
lange nicht gewesen ist und das liegt
nicht an deutschland das muss ich an
dieser stelle mal in aller klarheit
sagen das liegt daran dass putin
herrschaft sicherung betrieben hat durch
die stabilisierung der ukraine durch
aktionen der krim und durch ausschaltung
der opposition im eigenen lande und da
hat handel schafft wandel geschichte und
ergreifend sein scheitern bewiesen und
wir hätten wir reagieren sollen also ich
meine wäre
herr schröder an der macht geblieben und
hätte seinen freund in lupenreinen
demokraten putin nicht auch alle regeln
ob er sie kommen gar nicht drumherum mit
mit russland mit mario barth mal gesagt
russland ist unverrückbar es ist eine
ganz unbequeme botschaft
und man wird mit russland reden müssen
und dann müssen aber ich finde die
haltung dass wir an bestimmten
denn sagen ja jetzt wird der und der
sanktioniert die muss man erweitern man
muss diese sanktionen aus denen auf
diejenigen die von diesem system der
korruption und der unterdrückung
profitieren das ist das was navalny in
einem zeitungskommentar sehr zutreffend
beschrieben hat es reicht nicht aus ein
paar geheimdienstoffizieren reiseverbot
zu erteilen sondern muss diejenigen die
im wissen um das unrechtssystem bei sich
zu hause ihr geld hier in europa parken
endlich den zugriff auf dieses geld
machen das ist eine sprache die die
glaube ich verstehen und russland ist
unverrückbar das stimmt natürlich aber
russland ist auch ein land voller
menschen die nicht diesem unrechts und
mörderischen regime angehören sondern
die eigentlich in freiheit und ohne
dieses ausmaß an korruption leben wollen
und immer zu sagen russland ist und
verrückt man über diese landwasser zu
sprechen statt über die menschen zu
stellen der missverstanden wir haben
viel mühe darauf verwenden dass
weiterhin nicht wieder direkt dabei über
die heinrich böll stiftung
beispielsweise mit all den ball dass die
walbeobachter die stiftung memorial all
diejenigen die als unabhängige blogger
dort sind diese zivilgesellschaft
stärken deswegen plädiere ich für ein
gutes verhältnis zu den russinnen und
russen könne aber realistische politik
gegenüber der russischen regierung bin
ein bisschen entsetzt über seine eigene
naivität ich hätte morgen fotos gesehen
wie putin frau merkel an blumenstrauß
überreicht hätte gedacht wenigstens hat
er nicht wie trump die hände in den
taschen gelassen das ist das schon ein
fortschritt also das kann ja nicht der
maßstab sein dass gut organisierte als
tramp ja das ist das ist irgendwie also
man kriegt dann tatsächlich ich hatte
nicht gedacht dass mir eine
gesprächsrunde bei bild die augen
irgendwo öffnet aber was ist tatsächlich
war eine provokation eine subtile
herabwürdigung unserer kanzlerin und ich
finde ja ich finde ja man das so so so
wie du das gesagt hast sie ich das auch
hätte es aber wahrscheinlich in der
überreichung dieses blumenstrauß ist so
nicht ganz
frage sollte man blumen annehmen von
jemandem der menschen in berlin um
bringen lässt
nein sollte man nicht dann sollte man
auch gar nicht hinfahren genau dass ich
meine das ist nun wirklich auch ein akt
der höflichkeit
schluss es gibt da diese diplomatische
diesen unterschied zwischen reden und
blumenstrauß an ihrem lächeln daneben
stehen erst hat er eine ganz andere
symbole aber doch genau das macht eine
warme semmeln die frage aber das ist das
was du gerade gesagt dass das in der
ersten drei dieser alten männer darum
gebettelt haben da hätte ich sagen
müssen liebe freunde jetzt rede ich
jetzt halt mal die klappe hier das sind
das sind dinge was ich auch von von
mutti erwartet dass dieses ruhe aber das
ist das ist die stärkere wäre für mich
die stärkere geste gewesen habe ich
alles nicht mitbekommen hätte ich nie
erfahren wenn wir zusammen gesessen
hätten mit dem lächeln ja das ist das
ist ja genau das was putin wollte er
wollte sie in eine situation bringen wo
sie aus dem konzept das konzept kommt ja
denn was soll sie tun also du kriegst
blumen und das ist ungefähr so wie wenn
dir einen keks in den mund steckt also
automatisch lächelt man obwohl man sich
denken was ist denn was ist denn das ja
was soll den lauf hier wirklich dass da
irgendein mensch gesagt hat wir machen
die zu schnecke in dem wir blumen
überreichen das habe ich nämlich heute
als ich zum beispiel diese diesen
nachklapp auf das gespräch gestern da
hat ein mensch der sich offensichtlich
als coach betätigt heute tom leezer
hamburg hat ja genau kluger mann hat
viel das richtige gesagt sagt aber
derjenige der ich glaube scholz dazu
geraten hat diese geste zu machen dass
ihm geht der g-20 immer noch in der
wäsche hängt dem sollte man eine flasche
wein geben und dann hieß es man hätte
laschet davor warnen müssen diese
entschuldigung die er das war
interessant das hat der mann gesagt ich
hätte vielleicht für bei ard und zdf
gereicht aber nicht bei bild wo er sich
für dieses dämliche lachen entschuldigt
hat aber da sagt ja noch allen ernstes
da hätte ihm ein berater sagen müssen so
geht das nicht ich will keinen kanzler
dem ein berater vorhersagt pass mal auf
macht dann diese geste das bringt uns
was ich will auch keine kanzlerin der
man sagen muss meist im blumenstrauß weg
ich war mit ihr und ihre reaktion bisher
nicht zufrieden aber offensichtlich hat
ja jemand den putin gesagt wir machen
die klein in dem wir einen großen
blumenstrauß überreichen so viel terrain
der serie bei der putin selber bettel
nicht nur ein
wenn sie sagen das stimmt was gesagt
wird über die geste und des ab
würdigende dieses blumenstraußes dann
sollten sie sich die wortwahl gegenüber
angela merkel als mutti noch mal
überlegen ob das nicht auch eine
herabwürdigung sind ein total spannenden
punkten ja man sagen jetzt haben wir nur
zu überlegen das ist das ist völlig
richtig aber ich war weil du vorher sie
in dieser situation dass sie putin wie
ein ungezogenes kind waren sie hat eine
souveränität der mutter die ich eine
mutter unterstelle wie kann sagt du
trotz löffel behalte deine blumen du
hast mir gestern noch hier in die suppe
gespuckt heute das ist der ton den ich
mit mutti verbinde das hat nichts
herabwürdigende es nichts von oben herab
ich habe tiefsten respekt und meine
mutter hat mir oft gesagt du großkotz
die erwachsen die bäume auch nicht in
den himmel das ist für mich mode und
nicht die die die die kantige frau die
da an sich nun irgendwo von von von
putin zu regeln lässt aber da meine ich
genau wenn sich diese szene vor meinem
auge sehen dass mehr weiterreden während
unsere kanzlerin spricht hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass die sagt was ist hier los
sodass ist dass ich für mich eine la
merkel und der mörderische trotz löffel
der welt wladimir putin haben wir
gelernt
[Musik]